The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE VERGHESE: So
we're going to continue
talking about coding.
We're going to focus on
linear block codes, which
I introduced briefly last time.
But just to step back
a bit and remind you,
we're talking about this
piece of the overall channel.
So we've got the
source that's done
this source coding, compressing
all the bits coming out
of here.
So that one bit,
one binary digit,
carries a bit of information.
And now, we're actually
reintroducing redundancy
in a controlled way,
so that we can protect
the message across
the physical channel
with its noise sources
and distortions and so on.
Actually, I should be saying
binary digits at this point.
Because again, at this
point, the binary digit
doesn't carry a
bit of information.
We're introducing redundancy,
but I'll leave you now
to make the distinctions.
OK, at this point here
outside the source coding,
one binary digit is
one bit of information.
But now, when you start to
introduce the redundancy,
you've got binary digits
that are not necessarily
one bit of information
per binary digit.
In fact, it won't be.
And then across the
channel at the other end,
you do the decoding to try
and recover from any errors
that the channel might
have encountered.
And what we said last time
is that the key to this
is really to introduce
some space around the code
words that carry your messages.
So you might want to
expand your set of messages
into a longer code word, such
that a small number of errors
on each code word
will not flip you over
into another code word.
So you'll be able to
recognize the neighborhood
of the valid code words.
That's the basic idea.
So you're trying to put
some space around things.
So if you've got k bits
in your original message,
you've got 2 to the
k messages, right?
So k message bits, 2
to the k messages--
and what we're planning to do
now is, with this input stream
that's coming into
our channel coder,
we're going to take the stream
and break it up into blocks.
So each block will
have k message bits.
And then out come
a series of blocks,
but each block now
has the large number.
So we've got n bits.
OK.
So we've done some padding
here. n is greater than k.
And so you have the
possibility of 2
to the n possible
messages in those n bits,
but you're not going
to use all of them.
You're only going
to use 2 to the k,
and so you'll leave some
space around each valid code
word, all right?
So the code words
are selected from 2
to the k code words selected
from 2 to the n possibilities.
OK.
You get the idea there?
Yeah.
And we introduce this
notion of Hamming distance
then to measure the
size of the neighborhood
around the code word.
So we have the notion
of a Hamming distance,
which we'll abbreviate to HD.
And this is the Hamming
distance between two bit
streams or between
two, let's say, blocks.
And what this is is
the number of positions
in which they differ.
OK.
So it's a very simple notion
of distance between bit strings
or binary digit strings.
All right.
And what we then said is you
get certain desirable error
detection and error
correction properties
based on the minimum distance.
minimum Hamming
distance of a code,
we use the simple
little d for that.
That's the minimum distance
you find between any two code
words in the code.
So based on that, we said that--
we wrote it slightly
differently last time.
I'm writing it to give you yet
another way to think about it.
What we basically said
is, for instance, if you
had a valid code word
here, valid code word here,
this is just a schematic.
One hop, meaning one
bit change, brings you
to some other word which
is not a code word.
Then another bit change brings
you to some other word, not
a code word.
And a further one brings
you to a new code word.
That's Hamming distance three.
So if the minimum
distance you find
among all the spacings
between code words
is a distance of three, measured
as the Hamming distance,
then you can detect
up to two errors.
So if you went from this
code word in two hops,
you'd still not be
at a new code word.
So you know you've
made a mistake.
If you wanted to
correct errors, you
could correct up to one error
in this case assuming that you
have no more than one error.
If you ended up
here, you'd know it
had to have come
from this code word.
If you ended up
here, you know it
had to have come from the
code word on the right.
Now, you have to
be a little careful
if you're trying
to do correction
and detection at the same time.
So for instance, if
you end up over here
and if it's possible to
get up to two errors, then
you might think you've had one
error that brought you here.
And you might correct
to this point.
But if the way you
actually got there was two
hops from over here, then you've
done an incorrect correction.
OK.
So you've got to be
a little bit careful.
And that's what the third
case tries to deal with.
It allows you to deal with
combinations of correcting up
to a certain number of
errors and then detecting
a certain number.
So basically, what
it's saying is
that this entire
distance here has
to end up with a little gap.
You've got to be able
to make a number of hops
equal to the number of areas you
want to detect and still leave
enough space to get to a
code word unambiguously.
So in this particular
case, for instance,
you couldn't unambiguously
detect up to two errors
if you were doing error
correction for one.
But if I had this
picture, OK, this
is now Hamming
distance 4, 1 2, 3, 4.
I could correct
single bit errors,
and I could detect up to 2
because 2 errors would bring me
up to this point.
That's clearly an error that
I wouldn't try to correct,
but I'd recognize
it as an error.
OK, so that's what the third
case tries to account for.
You won't believe
how much time I
spent trying to distill that
statement down into a bullet.
And I don't know if
I got it right here,
but that's the idea.
OK.
So our focus today is
on linear block codes.
We're not talking about codes
in general, but linear codes.
This would be a general
statement for a block code.
I haven't said anything about
linearity up to this point.
All I said was take
blocks of k bits,
expand them to blocks of
n bits, and pick subsets
in this fashion.
That's just a general
statement about coding.
There's nothing linear
about this as stated.
So if you want to
impose linearity,
then you've got to introduce
this additional piece, which
is to say that every
bit in your code word
is going to be a linear
combination of bits
from your message.
And the easiest way to
understand that is the matrix
representation I had last time.
Do I have it on this slide?
Not yet, OK.
But I probably do on the
next, so let me pull that up.
OK.
So basically, you're going to
generate your code words, c.
So that's c1 up to cn is
going to be d1 up to dk times
some matrix, which
is k times n matrix.
And we'll call it G.
OK.
So that's referred to as the
generator matrix for the code.
We're talking about binary code.
So all of these are 0s or 1s.
And all of these
entries are 0 or 1.
And all computations
are done in GF(2).
They're done modulo 2.
Well, let me just say that
all operations are in GF(2).
OK.
So this is modulo 2 operations
or Boolean operations.
So if I'm working with the
symbols 0 and 1, what is 0,
minus 1?
How am I to interpret this?
I haven't quite defined it.
But how would you
interpret that?
You can think of it as the thing
I need on the right-hand side
that, when I add 1 to
both sides, I get 0.
Is that one way to think of it?
So 0 minus 1 is 1.
Or another way to say that is
minus 1 is the same as plus 1
in this setting.
OK.
So you just have to
get used to working
with only 0 and 1 in GF(2), but
we talked about that last time.
All right, so back
to the statement.
This is for a linear block code.
You're going to see
matrix multiplication
throughout your careers here.
So if you haven't
already seen them,
this is a good
opportunity to learn
about matrix multiplications.
So let's see, could
somebody tell me
what procedure I go
through to, let's say,
get the i-th position
here in terms
of what I do on
the right-hand side
if I want to get the i-th
position on the left-hand side?
What's the operation
that I'm thinking of?
Or let me ask you this.
Is the entire matrix
G relevant when
I'm just interested in
the i-th position here?
Or is this some part of G
that's what I should focus on?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The i-th column?
GEORGE VERGHESE: It's just
the i-th column, right?
So we think of
matrix multiplication
as sort of being
in the simple case.
If you want the
i-th position here,
it's kind of the dot product of
this row with the i-th column.
So if you want the
i-th position here,
let me give you a
particular example.
If I've got 1, 0, 1, 1 here
and I have 1, 1, 0, 0 here,
then this position is going to
be this is in the i-th column.
What I'm going to find
in the i-th column
is 1 times 1, which is 1,
plus 0 times 1, which is 0,
plus 1 times 0 plus 1 times 0.
So I just got a 1, right?
So I'm just going
to get a 1 or a 0
depending on the
specific entries here.
So look what we've done.
We've found a particular
position in the code word
as a linear combination of
the bits in the message.
We took the combination
of these bits
with the weights that
are displayed out here.
So that's really
what this statement
was on the previous slide.
We said that a code is linear.
Well, each of the k
message bits is encoded
as a linear transformation.
Sorry, each of the
code bits is encoded
as a linear transformation
of the message bits.
I didn't quite say
it that way there.
Let me say it here
on this slide.
So each code word bit is a
specified linear combination
of the message bits.
This is what I'm referring to.
If you wanted to find
any particular bit,
you're going to take a linear
combination of these bits
with the weights
that are here, OK?
There's another way
to think of this also
which is the other
blue line out there,
which is to think of the matrix
G as being made up of rows.
OK.
So can someone
describe to me what
we're doing with these rows to
get this into our code vector?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK.
So basically, the way
matrix multiplication works,
if you think about it, is
what we're going to be doing
is 1 times the first row
plus 0 times the second row
plus 1 times the third row
plus 1 times the fourth row.
So another way to think
of matrix multiplication,
it's going to generate this
vector as a linear combination
of the rows of this matrix, OK?
What linear combination--
well, the linear combination
that's described in the
message part of this.
So this is the message part.
So that's the other
statement out here.
So each code word is
a linear combination
of the rows of this
generator matrix.
So these are concrete
ways to think
about what a linear code is.
But we also saw that
there's another way
to think of it which is
in terms of this property,
that the sum of any two code
words is also a code word.
So if you have a
set of code words
with the property that the
sum of any two is another word
and that set, another
code word and that
set, then what you
have is a linear code.
And we argue that the all 0s
code word must be in there.
Because when you add
a code word to itself,
you get the all 0s
code word, right?
OK.
So that's the class of codes
we're going to be focusing on.
But I'm going to make a
further restriction, which
is that I'm going to
look at code words that
are of a very special type.
So I'm going to
limit myself to code
words that have this structure.
So here's my data
bits, d1 up to dk.
I'm going to pick my code word,
so that, let's say, the first k
bits are precisely
the data bits.
And then I'll pick
the additional ones
to be some set of what
we'll call parity bits.
So this is p1 up to pn minus k.
All right, so I'm not
going to have an arbitrary
transformation here.
I'm going to restrict
myself to transformations
that have the property that,
when I multiply by the data
vector here, what I get is
the data vector reproduced
in the initial part and
then a bunch of new bits
representing the
redundant relationships
that I'm computing.
We refer to them as parity bits.
It's not so important that the
data bits be in the first k
position, so I'm willing
to tolerate variations
of this where the data bits are
somewhere in this code vector.
But the key thing about what's
called a systematic code
is that, when I look at the code
word in designated positions,
I find the data bits and
the other positions are
the so-called
parity bits that are
obtained as linear combinations
of the data bits, OK?
So if you are familiar
with matrix operations,
then that what I'll
need is all the way down
the diagonal to
have a matrix that
has 1s along the diagonal,
0s everywhere else,
and then something here.
Let me just call this matrix
of left over 0s and 1s,
matrix A. OK.
So I've got here a k
times k matrix with 1s
down the diagonal and
0s everywhere else.
And then I've got a matrix
which has 0s and 1s in it.
This is going to be, what is
it, k times n minus k, right?
So do you buy this?
So think about how matrix
multiplication works.
If I want the first
column on the left,
I take this row inner
product or dot product
with the first column here.
That just selects out d1.
And indeed, I get the d1 there.
And that happens for
the first k positions.
Beyond that, I'm taking
linear combinations
with whatever sits here.
OK.
It turns out that this is
not really a special case.
It turns out that
any linear code
can be transformed to this
form by invertible operation.
So basically, if you use
invertible operations
on the rows here and some
rearrangement of the columns,
you can bring any
code to this form.
And then the resulting code will
have effectively the same error
correction properties that
the code out here did.
OK.
So we're just going
to limit ourselves
to thinking of
linear codes, which
are in the so-called
systematic form.
In other words, some
part of the code word
is the message bits and the
other part is parity bits, OK?
So let's look at a
specific code that
is of this form,
very simple code,
referred to as a
rectangular code.
And you see a particular
example on this slide here.
So what do we do?
We arrange our data
bits into a matrix
which could be
rectangular or square
depending on what you have.
So we're going to have r, rows,
and c, columns, with the data
bits in here, so D1, D2, all
the way up to D sub, let's say,
r times c, right?
In this particular case,
r and c are both 2.
And then you're going
to generate the parity
bits in the simple fashion.
What you're going to do is
choose a parity bit associated
with the first row that
basically makes sure
that in the first row,
including the parity bit,
you've got an even number of 1s.
OK.
So this is a choice
for even parity here.
Similarly, P2 will
be chosen such
that the second row
has even parity.
In other words, you've got
an even number of 1s there.
And for the columns, similarly,
P3 will be chosen such that D1
and D3 and P3 together
have even parity.
In other words, the number
of 1s in that column is even.
Again-- the same
thing for this column.
So what you're
trying to do is sort
of have sentries on the
rows and columns that
will signal when
something has happened
to a bit of the intersection.
That's the general
idea here, all right?
So you'll take this out
and arrange it then.
So you've got your parity bits.
What's the sequence I used--
P1, P2 and then more parity
bits here, OK, so row
and column parity bits.
So here's a way to think about
what these are explicitly.
So what you'll do
is P1 is D1 plus D2.
When I say plus, of
course, I mean in GF(2).
So that's modulo
2 addition, right?
Does that simple
formula ensure that I've
got an even number of 1s
in that first row, right?
If D1 is 0 and D2
is 1, then I'll
make this equal to 1,
which is what I need.
If D1 and D2 are both
1, I'll make this 0,
which is what I need and so on.
So this simple
expression captures it
and similarly for the r-th row.
So for each row,
you make the parity
bit equal to the sum of the
data bits in that row, similarly
for the columns, OK?
Another thing, by
the way, can you
tell me what P1 plus D1 plus
D2 is going to be in this case?
If I pick P1 in
this fashion, what
does it guarantee for
P1 plus P2 plus D2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry?
GEORGE VERGHESE: 0, right?
Because really I'm taking
P1 and adding P1 again.
And when I take something and
add it to itself in GF(2),
I get 0.
So this is equal to 0.
So these are just
two different ways
of thinking about
the parity bit here.
So this is how you
compute the parity bit,
whereas this might be referred
to as parity relation.
It's a linear constraint
relating the parity
bit and the data bit.
In fact, we might try
constructing this matrix
as we go, right?
So we've got D1, D2,
D3, D4, P1, P2, P3, P4.
Whoops.
And here is D1, D2, D3, D4.
I'm going to have my
generator matrix here.
It's got the identity
matrix in this first part.
We use the symbol capital
I for identity matrix.
So when you see
identity matrix, you
know it's a square matrix
with 1s down the diagonals.
OK.
So what goes in the
next column over here
for this particular example?
The next column over
is going to be P1.
P1 is D1 plus D2.
So what I need is
1, 1, 0, 0, right--
and similarly for
the other parity bit.
So once you're
told the rule here,
it's easy to generate the
matrix that goes with it.
OK.
So let's get some practice
figuring out what's what here.
This is all we're
going to be aiming
to do in this lecture is
construct codes that correct up
to a single error.
So we're focusing on
Single-Error Correction codes
or what are referred
to as SEC codes,
OK, Single-Error Correction.
So assume that only one error
has happened or zero errors.
You don't get more
than one, let's say.
If you receive this, I've
just rearranged the code word
into the pattern that allows
you to look at this very easily.
So here's D1, D2,
D3, D4, and so on.
Any errors here in this?
You can see that, if I
look along the first row,
I've got even parity, even
parity, even parity, even
parity.
So everything looks fine.
And I'll declare that
there are no errors.
On the other hand,
if I receive that,
OK, so here I have a parity
check failure, right?
And so I know that something
is wrong in this column.
I look along the rows.
I see a parity check
failure in that row.
So I pinpoint the error as
being at the intersection
of those two.
And I know that's the bit
that I have to flip, OK?
And another case, here
there is a failure on a row,
but nothing on the
corresponding columns.
So what that tells us, it's
actually the parity bit that's
failed, right?
Everything else looks fine,
but the parity bit has failed.
If there's a single
error to correct,
it would be to
convert this 1 to a 0.
And then all parity
relations are satisfied.
OK.
So you can get errors
in the parity bits
as easily as you get
them in the data bits
because the channel doesn't
know the difference.
The channel is just
seeing a sequence of bits.
All right, so this is
how you work backwards
to figure out what's going on.
Another way to say it--
and we'll see this
later-- is you
get what should be D1 and
D2, but you're not sure
yet whether they're
in error or not.
So let me call them D1
and D2 prime for now.
So you compute your estimate of
the first parity relationship
and compare it with
what's sitting in--
well, let me say,
are these equal?
So what you're doing
is you're computing
your estimate of the
parity relationship
based on what's sitting in the
code word in these positions
and seeing whether it's equal to
what you think it should equal.
OK.
And if it's equal, then you
say that parity relation
is satisfied.
And otherwise, you
try and make a change.
Now, we'll see how to do
this more systematically
next lecture, actually,
when we'll go further
with the matrix story.
But I'm just trying to get
you a little oriented here.
OK.
So you probably believe
by now that this code can
correct single errors, right?
The rectangular code can
correct single errors.
Basically, an error
in a message bit
is pinpointed by parity
errors on the row and column.
A message in a parity bit is
pinpointed by just an error
in the parity row or column.
And if you get something
other than that,
then you say you have an
uncorrectable error, right?
You're not set up to do things
with other errors there.
But now, how do we know
the Hamming distance is 3?
The minimum Hamming
distance is 2.
We know that, if the minimum
Hamming distance is 3,
we can correct a single error.
But it's possible that the
minimum Hamming distance
is greater than 3 for this
case, which might mean
we have more possibilities.
So how can we establish what
the minimum Hamming distance is?
Any ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the case
in which the Hamming distance
is [INAUDIBLE] change
one of the data bits
and and the two parity bits
that correspond [INAUDIBLE]..
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK.
So am I going to search all
pairs-- so the suggestion was
change something until you
find the Hamming distance of 3.
And presumably, you won't
find anything smaller, right?
OK.
Because we know we can
correct single errors.
But am I going to search
through all pairs of code words
to do this?
Or can I do something better?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if you have [INAUDIBLE]..
GEORGE VERGHESE:
So you're giving me
a particular
computation here, but I
don't know that you've answered
my question, which was,
am I going to have to search
through all pairs of code words
to see that I can establish
a known distance of 3?
Or is there something simpler
than that that I can do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Can you speak up?
My hearing is not great, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] high
dimensional [INAUDIBLE]..
It's whatever minimum Hamming
distance is [INAUDIBLE]..
GEORGE VERGHESE: Oh, so you've
got a general formula, OK.
Can you invoke
linearity in some way?
Because I haven't heard you
use the linearity of the code
in anything you've said.
Were you going to
offer a suggestion?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what
happens when you [? put one ?]
[INAUDIBLE] when you [INAUDIBLE]
parity [INAUDIBLE] you
pick one bit you have
to put two other bits.
[INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK.
So I think I get what
your argument is.
You're saying start from
an arbitrary message bit.
And then if you make any
flip, you'll get at least 3.
That may have been
the earlier argument,
which I missed, right?
Is there a way to invoke
the linearity of the code
in making these arguments?
You're on the right
track, but I just
want to see if linearity
can be invoked.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
you can use the all 0
codes and [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE VERGHESE: Right.
So what we've established
is that, for a linear code,
the minimum Hamming distance
is the minimum weight
among all non-0 vectors, right?
So all you have to do
is start with the 0 code
word, everything 0, and then
flip a bit in the message
and then see if you get
Hamming distance 3 or greater.
OK.
So we can start with
the 0 code word.
I guess that's the point
I was going to make here.
OK.
There is another expression
that popped up there
before completing that argument.
Do you agree with what it
said about the code rate?
It says the code rate is
rc over rc plus r plus c.
Do you agree with that?
Yeah.
Because we have the number
of message bits being rc.
And then the total number
of bits is rc plus r plus c.
So the rate is, indeed, what's
given by that expression.
OK.
And then we'll go on to make
this argument about the three
cases here.
So you can actually
go case by case.
And the argument
here is actually
closer to what was being
described out there.
It doesn't start
with the 0 message.
But it says, if you've
got two messages that
differ in 1 bit in
the message area,
then they're going to differ by
1 bit in the associated parity
areas.
And, therefore, the overall
code word has moved by 3.
And then you go through
each of the cases,
and you argue that you've
moved by at least 3.
So this argument is
actually closer to what
was being suggested earlier.
OK.
So you can go through
each of the cases
and discover that the nearest
code word you can get to
is Hamming distance
3 away, all right?
Why is it that we're flipping
a bit in the message section
to decide what's a new case?
The way we count
our code words is
by arranging through all
the possible 2 the k, right?
So we've got to flip
bits in the data section
to get to another code word.
So we're saying we have
a code word corresponding
to some set of data bits.
We'll flip a bit there, and then
look to see what happens, OK?
OK.
So here's a little
modification to the code,
which actually puts in an
overall parity bit, P here.
So what this is is the
sum of all the entries
and every other position.
OK.
And if you go through
the argument there,
what you'll discover is what
you've done is go from--
do I still have it on the board?
I might have it
on the board here.
No.
What you've done is go from
the rectangular code that
had this structure, Hamming
distance 3, to now one that
has Hamming distance 4.
OK.
So adding that
overall parity bit
has increased the minimum
Hamming distance of the code
from 3 to 4.
Does that improve error
correction capabilities?
You still can only
correct up to one error.
But the difference now is
that, if you get two errors,
you can actually detect it
accurately as a 2-bit error.
OK.
All right, so I'll leave you
to go through that analysis.
This we've pretty
much done already.
This has just filled out
the rest of the matrix.
You see that we filled out
this column on the board.
That was this case.
But you can actually
fill them all out
once you have the description
of the parity check bits.
OK.
So these other columns you
can fill out similarly.
And this is for the case of--
let's see, what case is
it referring to here?
n equals 3.
Let's see-- sorry, n equals 9.
k equals 4.
d equal 4.
So what rectangular picture
am I talking about here?
This is a rectangular code.
What rectangular code
has these parameters?
So I must be
talking about 2 by 2
for the data bits, 2 rows, 2
columns, and then 1 overall,
right?
The overall, what gives
me the clue is I've
got a minimum distance of 4.
If it's a rectangular code
with minimum distance 4,
then I know I must have
an overall parity bit.
k is 4 because I just
have 4 data bits.
And overall, I've got to
send 9 bits in each block.
OK.
So for that
particular case, this
is what the matrix looks like.
So the only difference is
there is an overall parity bit
here, P5, which is the
sum of all the data bits.
Actually, all the data
bits on the parity bits,
but this is what
it works out to be.
OK.
And we've pretty much talked
through the decoding here.
Let me put it all up there.
So you calculate
all the parity bits.
If you see no parity errors,
you return all the data bits.
If you detect a row or
column parity bit error,
then you make the change in
that particular position.
And otherwise, you flag
an uncorrectable error.
So the correction
is straightforward.
If you look on the
slides later, you'll
see a little quiz that you
can try for yourselves.
Or you might try
it in recitation.
But let me pass on that.
OK.
So the question arises,
is a rectangular code
using this redundant
information in an efficient way?
Or could we do better?
So let's see, we've got a code
word that's got k message bits.
And then it's got n
minus k parity bits.
OK.
So here's the data bits.
Here's the parity bits.
We want to use the parity bits
as effectively as possible.
How many different
conditions can we
signal if we have P bits that
can only take value 0 or 1?
Just 2 to the n minus
k conditions, right?
So if we're looking
at the code word
and trying to deduce something
from the parity bits,
how many different
things can we deduce?
Well, n minus k
bits can signal 2
to the n minus k
different things, right?
What do they have to signal?
What do the parity
bits have to tell us?
They have to tell us either
that an error didn't occur
or that an error occurred
in the first position
or second position or third
all the way up to the n-th.
So the number of things we want
to learn from the parity bits
is n plus 1.
So you would hope
that this is true,
that the number of things you
can signal with the parity bits
is at least equal to
the number of things
you want to get in the case
of single-error correction.
All right, we're only trying
to correct a single error here.
So we want the number of
possibilities that the parity
bits can indicate to include
the case of no errors--
that's the 1 over there--
plus the case of an error
in the first position
or second position or
third position and so on.
OK.
If you plug in the
typical parameters
for the rectangular code,
you'll see that you're actually
exceeding this wildly.
Let's see.
For that particular case,
9, 4, 4, what do we have?
We have 9 plus 1 on this side.
And we have 2 to the what--
9 minus 4.
So what's that-- 32
on the right-hand side
and 10 on the left.
So you've got a big gap.
If you were going to allow me
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, parity bits,
I could do a lot
more than tell you
what you're asking me to tell
you in this particular code.
So I'm not using the parity
bits as efficiently as I could.
And that motivates the
search for better choices.
So this is a fundamental
inequality here, something
we'll keep referring back to.
So make sure you understand
where that comes from.
And that leads us to what
are called Hamming codes.
So Hamming codes are codes
that actually use the parity
bits efficiently in that they
match this bound with equality.
OK.
So can you think of
the smallest k and n
pair that's going to satisfy
this with equality just playing
with some small numbers?
Maybe I shouldn't play
this game since we're
late on the lecture.
Here's a suggestion, nkd.
The Hamming code is going to be
a single-error correcting code
with minimum Hamming distance 3.
So the 3 will always be there.
This is n, and this is k.
And you'll see that this
is satisfied with equality.
But there are other choices.
This is the smallest choice,
the smallest non-trivial choice
anyway.
But you can go to more
general possibilities.
So this code is
called a perfect code
because it matches that
inequality with equality,
but actually that
doesn't necessarily
mean it's the best code.
It turns out to be
a good code provided
you're picking these
parameters appropriately
for your application.
But this is perfect code
in a very technical sense,
meaning it's a code that attains
this inequality with equality.
OK, that's all that
it means there.
OK, so what's the idea
on the Hamming code?
Let me put it all down there,
and then we'll talk through it.
So this little Venn
diagram conveys for you
how the parity bits are picked.
And they end up actually being
picked in a very efficient way
to provide the
coverage you want.
So this is the case that
was mentioned before.
This is the, was it, 7, 4, 3.
Is that what we had?
Yeah, 7, 4, 3, right?
So let's give ourselves
some space here.
So with 3 parity
bits, we're actually
going to indicate
whether there was 0 error
or whether the error occurred
in the first position,
second position, and
so on, all the way up
to the seventh position.
So we're going to use
3 bits, 3 parity bits,
to indicate eight
possibilities, which is what we
know you should be able to do.
And here's the arrangement.
This picture conveys it.
So basically, P1 is
D1 plus D2 plus D4.
So P1 fires if D1, D2, or
D4, if any one of those
is 1 and similarly for
these other things.
OK.
So this picture tells
you what data bits
are included in the
coverage of each parity bit.
So that's the way to think
of what this picture is.
So these are
apportioned carefully.
So for instance,
let's see, if you
discover that P1 and P3
indicate an error, that
means some data bit
in the coverage of P1
and in the coverage
of P3 have an error.
But P2 didn't have an error.
OK.
So what does that tell you?
We're only considering
up to single errors.
If P1 and P3 have an error,
but P2 doesn't have an error,
well, P1 and P3 share D2, D4.
But P2 didn't have an
error, so D4 must be fine.
So D2 must be the one
that's an error, OK?
And so you get full coverage
by that kind of reasoning.
One way to think of this,
and this is actually
how Hamming set it up, was he
actually arranged the parity
bits and the data bits
a little differently
down that code word.
He had parity bit 1
in the first position,
parity bit 2 in the second
position, parity bit 3
in the fourth position.
If you had a long code
word, the next one
would be in the eighth position.
So it's 2 to the 0, 2 to the
1, 2 to the 2, 2 to the 3,
and so on.
So those are the positions in
which he puts the parity bits.
Everywhere else
are the data bits.
And then the data bits that
feed into parity P1 or parity
relation P1 are the
data bits and positions
that end with a 1.
OK.
So if the positions
end with the 1,
you stick them in the coverage
of this parity relationship,
so D1, D2, not D3, but D4.
For P2, similarly,
the parity relation P2
includes the data
bits that have a 1
in their second position, so
D1, not D2, yes D3, and yes D4.
OK.
So the nice thing about
that is that, when
you get a particular
pattern of errors,
it actually leads you exactly to
the right position in the code
word.
So I don't want to actually
spend a lot of time here.
I want you to look
at that separately.
But just to go over the
process, here's what happens.
We know that parity bit
P1 was D1 plus D2 plus D4.
So we know that this parity
relationship was satisfied
at the transmitting end.
By the time you receive
all of this, all of it
might have been corrupted.
That's why I put a little
primes next to these.
Not all of them, but one
of them may have been.
We're limiting ourselves to a
single-error correction, OK?
So the D1 prime may not
be D1 because of an error.
So what you do is you compute
these so-called syndrome bits.
If there were no errors, then
E1 should be 0, E2 should be 0,
E3 should be 0 because that's
how it was on the other end.
If there's a single error
in one of the bits covered
by the appropriate
relationship, you're
going to get the associated
syndrome bit going to 1.
So you compute these syndromes
and then line them up
as a binary number.
And it turns out that,
depending on the pattern
of the syndromes,
it'll tell you exactly
the position and the code word
in which there's an error.
So it's kind of
cute and powerful.
You can correct up to t errors.
And there's a
natural relationship
that extends from this.
I wanted to make one
final point, which
is that these error correcting
codes occur all over the place,
not just in the
setting of binary.
And one thing you
might try and DO
if you're carrying
a textbook with you,
look at the ISBN number.
The ISBN number is a 10
digit number x1 up to x10.
And it turns out that 1 times
x1 plus 2 times x2 plus 10 times
x10 is going to be 0 modulo 11.
So try that out on the
ISBN number of any book
you're carrying.
What you'll see is that this
is a parity relationship that
guards against errors
in any single ISBN
number or a
transposition of two,
which turn out to be the
two most natural errors.
OK.
Look for parity relations
in other places.